hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots so um let me we got new to
listener so we got to give a quick
background here so so there's this guy
that we've been how many years like 4 or
five years now at least uh Dayton
hypernova um he is a [__] oh we could
talk openly about him AKA Cade paradoxa
yeah he's a [__] who has lived with
his parents he's 38 now and he always
accused his brother of beating him up I
I I I would recommend go to ROTC clips
on YouTube and just search for Dayton
hypernova we have an entire playlist
from the beginning to now it's cut it up
into one big thing don't we have like a
Dayton omnius I thought we cut I don't
know if we have an omnius for D we do
have a playlist we do have a playlist
though but you know what a dayon Omnibus
isn't bad we should maybe do that um
yeah so uh his brother died of
alcoholism well I mean because of
alcoholism and dball said rip big shm
yeah so here we go oh wait can I read
the title first of course please who
Christmas Friday December 2022 shouting
from right-wing biger mom gaslighting me
and I shout about her skinhead Son dead
her his dead brother his dead brother
who's famously dead for like two years
years two years now better do it
religion tells you to be different in
the way that you are oh he's doing the
[__] typical I don't believe in Jesus
but I'm going to tell you about your
religion tells you to honor thy father
by being honorable
boom yes by being honorable but what's
be what's honorable about you on any
level do you have any honor his dad just
died of cancer recently too don't forget
that
mhm this I have to be honorable to do
that and that is what I'm can I can I
point out the most important part of
this video yeah what does Dayton get
paid $100 a week to do laundry what's
his mom currently doing
laundry I hate this dude so much
the fact that Dayton still breathes
makes me question whether there is a God
yeah you know what happens when I see an
old lady like that picking like laundry
up off the ground even if it's not my
mom I go hey don't worry about let me
grab that for you I stop it you don't
need to be bending over and getting up
go go sit down on a step by the way on a
step just just relax I got you're on
camera right now saying that wrong kid
died yeah yeah he's on camera see the
only people that watch your videos are
us and it's to make fun of you that's
fine with with me cuz God Merry
Christmas God sees everything and he he
saw all the beatings that happened on
that floor right there hey Dayton maybe
God was beating you up cuz you're being
a [__] mhm it's all it's all God's plan
son happened right where you are
standing right there I am not going to
know what I'm aware that's the
difference I'm not going the mama as the
old lady hump I can't wait for Dayton to
be
shouting alone in this foreclosed house
as the power is getting shut off and
there's nobody left when his mom dies
it's he's going to be alone shouting at
ghosts about how his brother beat him in
the house like a [__] ghoul storm
shelter says she has a hunchback from
picking up all his [__] yeah yeah going
to know what I'm going to be aware and
that is what you have chosen your entire
life to not be about trauma to other
people oh man the homeless Arc is going
to be [__] lit oh Dane I'm look look
look man I cannot wait I cannot [__]
wait you owe me money and that's it
worthless words worthless absolutely
that's your Bible that you don't read
when you speak it to other people
imagine thinking your parents owe you
money can you believe that on any level
believe that like what what a [__]
what a [__] [__] this guy is the
Bible you know like if my parents were
still alive do you know how proud I
would be to have this show and be able
to go out and be like hey you know what
big dick Daddy's picking up dinner
tonight whatever you want you know what
I mean dollarita on me hey you want hey
unlimited mozzarella sticks hey you know
what let's get the whole appetizer
platter let's go [__] nuts oh [__]
hey pessy we got any sampo platters back
there I'm [__] starving yeah I want
the boneless wings with the potato skin
thank you I'm sorry Frozen ran through
here and he just [__] took out he had
like this like plastic bag and he just
dumped it all in there and left I hate
him wealth mentality while you abuse
people that bald head man he's too
confident now of a talks about it
constantly you never quote that book I I
wish you would read the book of acting
on your impulse to kill yourself yeah
seriously is the most important one
about your behavior also the book of
Acts if I recall correctly if I recall
correctly the book of Acts is in the Old
Testament I might be wrong on that but
if it is that's Jewish gobbl cook no no
it's it's the New Testament oh is
it stop no Jewish gobbledygook is
actually a dish with a noodle
uh chicken and and there's some carrots
that hump on her back is concerning me
it is concerning me up people when you
are the problem Oh you think he needs to
be drained she looks like she looks like
she should be yelling about trumpet yes
tolerant of your ignorance she's just
yelling at this old lady I move out why
don't I move out I
oh please move move out sell the house
sell the house get a little condo yes
move out move out to Arizona where the
airs dryer you'll live longer yes reason
why because you started this by
aggravating me should just
go what is wrong with you you're you're
38 years old never paid rent and
screaming at your mother after your dad
died of cancer and your brother died of
liver failure I like how he backtracks
her right away he's like hey hey calm
down what's wrong with you you won't
have to deal with Mom what is wrong with
you oh Irish she have to move out no no
no sorry there's a little background
here last week we we learned cuz we've
been talking to some people around the
family um that send us messages when
she's what the reason he's freaking out
about maybe I should leave because she's
been threatening for a bit because he's
being insufferable she can't maintain
that house by herself so she's been
threatening to just sell the house and
move yeah look we hate [__] Boomers
that do this but this is one of the few
Boomers that were like sell the house
don't give them [__] why would look at
her she's been taking care of him for
his whole life this this is one of the
only Boomers that gets full RC approval
to get the RV and hit the road go enjoy
yourself remember when he yelled at his
cancer stricken dad because he ordered
pizza from the wrong pizza place mhm do
you remember when he stole his mother's
credit card so you could buy outfits on
Amazon to run his store in Dayton Ohio
where you don't have to pay and you can
only give what you want that was a
business model by the way look it
up turns out people in Dayton will just
take [__] yeah I love how he's just like
you just you and Dad just stood idly by
while I was beaten in this home and
she's like all right fine I'm going to
leave okay now now now we're acting
that's what I'm saying he's like hey
whoa what's wrong with you calm down
what are we what are we talking about
here we're all getting a little CRA I
got a little crazy you got a little
crazy come on look at us look at us this
back and forth
look you said something I said something
classic us look at us is the funny look
at us up to our always again anyway I'm
gonna go order a pizza with your credit
card I'll be back from the good place
from the good place remember remember
Health burritos he loves eating Health
burritos your own problems you point
people as the problem when you are
[__] Lefty [__] he is huh seriously a
trauma inducing [__] I'm sorry for
cussing it's Christmas and you shout at
me this is Christmas Day by the way
sorry she's shouting at you I bet she
started it I bet I bet the [__] I bet
the old lady with the hump at her back
doing laundry was really Bo up on you
yeah I'm sure she's not going through
the fact of trying to deal with the
first Christmas without her husband who
just died of cancer oh my God and like
the second Christmas without her son
without her son her favorite son her
favorite yeah the good one shouting oh
don't start that you started at shouting
you started before I even started
recording right now notice how
everything happens off camera all the
violence of him happens off camera stop
being exactly what you don't like and do
what Jesus told you
do no you don't do what Jesus told you
to do yeah I'm sorry you eat you you you
[__] take Xanax and suck [__] you're
a [__]
degenerate hey but if you want your mom
to [__] follow the Bible to the tea
she should take you up to a mountain and
[__] kill stab you that is true has
to be just specifically a Christian J
even realize that that's just common
sense that's common sense to that
religion it's sad it's sad that you
could be that
abusive it's Christmas and I'm trying to
be nice but don't push people that are
this is him on
Christmas trying to be nice I've been
through plenty because Chistmas time is
here wow she's just like look look look
look look that's the photo of her
husband who passed away what a Chad yeah
I know I know how did he make him
Jesus she's just listening to to to
[__] her
Evangelical
so there's some people that maybe just
knew people that walked in on this and
don't know what he looks like if you
want to
properly properly hate Dayton you have
to see
Dayton I could hear my younger brother
on the phone with my mom like yelling at
her almost like he was really really
what a piece of [__] wow who yells at
mother why he disrespect her like that
why can you believe somebody would yell
at their
mother wow who does that like adamantly
angry I'm like my younger brother never
raises his voice to by oh my God look at
his arms oh bad my God he been
scratching yeah he looks like when uh
remember when uh Benny and the soprano
stuck Arty bu's [__] hand in the
boiling sauce that's it looks like bro
he looks like when you pick the casing
off of pepperoni he looks like he looks
like he looks like he has Deadpool's
arms exactly he does have Deadpool's
arms he so keep it guys so here's the
thing he's he's trans right what he
calls himself Kade paradoxa but Dayton
hypernova is the name of his ban Channel
whatever um he's so hated that even the
gay LGBT community want nothing have
spoken out openly that they hate
him um he is he says he's a girl but he
still goes out with girls he still dates
girls and looks like a dude yeah looks
like a gay dude mhm our mom at all even
though all this bad stuff happened to me
you know that he allowed as well all of
them allowed all this crazy [__] that
happened by the [__] skin head in the
family oh my god dude give a [__] about
any of that and he you know stayed
silent and quiet and completely un
involved uh about all that violence and
PTSD and [__] and like basically he he
never raises his voice to her at all
because she's he's he's like you know he
he like just obeys All Things No matter
how uh bad if it's you know her telling
him you know to stay out of it and he's
yelling at her or not yelling but he
really loud arguing and I'm like what is
going on so like over here and they're
talking about they're like having a big
argument about the freaking uh War thing
the war going on oh you were wondering
what Dayton's stance was on the
Palestine Israel conflict don't worry
we're about to find out no the
Palestinian thing went on um with Israel
like it's crazy like and my mom is like
you know we're today Christian country
and my brothers like [__] those [__]
[__] yeah sounds like your younger
brother's based yeah the one thing that
they ever argued about ever look and I
just relate so much with Palestine
because you know like my brother was
this like big strong force in the house
and he oppressed me every chance he
got so then my mom said that she just
want to pray for my brother and my
little brother was like you know like
you know Israelis invented Hamas
actually because the
PLO a long time I don't hear my brother
says watch this guy named Stu
Peters it's like I was following Lucas
Gage on Twitter and Jake Shields and
then they told me that half the people
that died at that music festival were
actually members of the IDF but then my
mom said that she like watched Ben
Shapiro and he she she watches Tom
McDonald guy she doesn't normally like
rap music you're in the background doing
video
[Laughter]
you arguing with mom ever on the phone
for any reason like he I mean he allowed
a skin head to beat the hell out of me
and then and then he's like you know and
don't even get me started on the USS
Liberty it's like oh my
God he said of people in Congress
shouldn't have citizenship to two
countries all right
buddy
up in the chat said Israel gave Hamas
$100 a week to do
laundry is that what happened over there
and that's the
story that's crazy I mean he literally
saw me as a second class citizen in that
situation well you are you're first
first of all you're covered in psoriasis
you're trans and you're a [__] whiny
[__] with no job remember the video
where he was sweeping up his skin
flakes
you what look like somebody was making
zeppoles that's why I never get the
sandwich it flakes on you it flakes on
you you got to get the one from Wawa it
doesn't flake it doesn't flake as
much yeah it's bad when you don't know
where your arms end and the sandwich
begins biting your fingers off Jes isn't
your French bakery
arms [__] croissant arms yeah [__]
really bad assle looks like he got
sunburned at the beach but he was
wearing
[Laughter]
gloves my own fault for not moving out
was his mentality even though my whole
body was bleeding head to toe from Ric
psoriasis which a genetic for my mom's
all right listen hear me out on this is
why I love we're not on YouTube anymore
hear me out on this Dayton have you
considered
yourself have you at least thought about
it t do me a favor just spitball when
you clip this for YouTube can you bleach
that bleep that out change it to like
love
yourself thank you I'm just saying have
you thought about
it just just thought about it just
thought about just thought about just
matter I want to matter of factly say
that in someone's face one day like when
they're genuinely going through a
divorce or a crisis have you thought
about killing
yourself do that one too taper twice you
got to do it yeah I'm sorry we're giving
you so much work
taper here's the here's the here I'm
going to post a link to the playlist for
you in the chat there you
go no empathy and call yourself a
liberal it's crazy like he's considered
the most liberal person in the family
and he didn't give a [__] about what was
yeah that's why's that's why he's not
for Israel yeah that's actually what
happened B skin headit over twice my S
was beating me on a regular basis I had
to stay in my room at all times wait is
this Dayton's Pro is Arch well my body
was bleeding from stress I
mean like we have like shared Jud
Christian vales I was thinking of going
over to Israel and join the IDF yeah
paulon and babies are just kicking time
bombs what is he like [__] Earnest
what is he going to go to jail after
that Dayton Goes to Jail Dayton goes to
Gaza look the tunnel goes to Africa the
tunnels in New York were perfectly
innocent hey Vern we're going to carpet
bomb this this Palestinian
Hospital almost B Shapiro maybe those
people just like living in
sewage related it bleeds all over from
any kind of stress so that whole
Dayton's like one of those people from
like the X-Men movie where they tried to
turn him into a mutant but like his
powers just bleeding you know I mean
like his body his body rejected the X
Gene oh [__] he ignored all of that and
like he for whatever reason they got
into a Spiel downstairs I can hear them
talking oh nice appropriate word for
this spiel's good spiel's great when
you're talking about this the
Palestinian thing going like going on in
the Middle East it's like crazy cuz
they're like arguing like really loudly
I mean I thought they were yelling at
each other at first it's
crazy smart move denen Palestinians love
trans people you should go over there
and help you should help enlist in the
fight go go help him out you know who
also likes trans people acidic Jews you
really should go you should yeah you
could be a Massad
agent honestly you should go fight with
the Jews because just like the Jews you
can't go you can't get over every minor
perceived slight from years ago you've
been milking the Sherman thing the way
they milk the Holocaust God you're
right he beats me he beats me in this
West
Bank are you sec really recording her
again before I started recording this
she said uh CNN is a joke it's like CNN
is news channel on a daily basis based
crazy I bet she likes Jesse
Waters Jesse water down Tucker is what I
call
[Music]
it
oh she's Pro isra she's is she's Fox
News why are you recording your mom on
the phone like that's weird it's super
weird so
weird by the way she's making it sound
like they're screaming and fighting but
it actually just seems like they're
having like a normal conversation
they're having a little little a little
discussion
that's it d That's that was that was
your that was some good evidence bro
yeah yeah no you're right yeah she won't
recover from this you should call the
police wow we're getting a whole [__]
slew dating stuff
today I love it what can I trans sister
and brother-in-law take huge Furniture
downstairs with ease ignored beatings
ignored beatings I just different from
the other kids are downstairs I think
they're parts of the bed that was in my
mom's room um my mom is throwing her bed
away it sounds like to get a new
one and there's really
heavy Furniture pieces fascinating did
you help her well no he can't he's
bleeding from all of his skin my
sister's a very heavy set
woman are you great big fat person come
on
man and and her husband is I'd rather
hang out with your fat sister and her
black husband than you I really would is
they're an interracial
couple it's like 2024 bro who calls it
an interracial
couple she's m she's miserating with a
black guy she's consorting with these
people and lying with them mhm although
that that would explain that she's
heavier
set it's like cuz I used to read for
like George Lincoln Rockwell and he said
we shouldn't crossbreed with these
people a skin head who is beating the
hell out of me over the span of and the
problem is is that the baby's going to
grow up and he's not going to fit in an
e world oh that's that's the best part
about being at racial I'll fit in
everywhere people by the way for those
who don't know new people here his his
real name is Earl
Schultz Earl Schultz
the most dating Ohio name ever it is I
weigh like I only weigh about 120 pounds
and I probably weigh less than that
there's a Multiverse where like like
Earl's just Earl and he's like a working
man and he's like a brother Paul Bear
his brother's funeral yeah and like he
was he was gone from for years but now
he's back home helping
out first times that he was beating me
because I was anemic thin and uh during
all of that they never and what are you
dating if he's anemic thin what what are
you a
[__] he what else are you got that's
about it answered it that's all he
is without even remember when he dad his
dad his sick dad who loved his son so
much that he still drove him like super
far to go see Christina RI at a Comic
Con dude there's so much lore that you
guys really have to check out this guy's
this guy rules in a not the good way not
a good way you got to start from the
beginning and you really got to go
through whimper basically I mean
remember when he like attacked his
brother at a restaurant yes it was an
Outback okay was an Outback Steakhouse
weren't they having wine did restaurant
with air quotes Okay literally having
wine at Outback which no wine was Chris
the Christmas Day house they're at the
house and he broke a wine glass on his
brother's head we did see that oh yeah
yeah yeah oh let me some donations dball
money schlomo baggin with a z my
favorite dating moment is was seeing his
skin flake covered bedroom oh God Meg
that was bad thank you meglin uh Tom
Rose Mercedes can we start beef between
him and jrc 3 so they'll beat the [__]
out of each other sure sounds good won't
happen but yeah they're both cowards
yeah what about the karate I can't I
have a court injunction okay that's why
I'm not even posting on gab anymore
okay